but first chief White House
correspondent John Roberts and what the
president did today good evening John
good evening to you Chris the stock
market didn't like it one bit neither
did the Chinese but here in Washington
mixed reaction to the president's latest
moves on trade in what aides call a
historic event President Trump took aim
at a favorite target today what he is
repeatedly called China's unfair trade
practices announcing his intention to
impose tariffs on select Chinese goods
in particular with China we're going to
be doing a section 301 trade action it
could be about 60 billion dollars White
House officials say the tariffs are
protective not punitive that the
president is not out to punish China he
simply wants to recover damages from
years of inequity in trade policy we're
doing things for this country that
should have been done for many many
years we've had this abuse by many other
countries and groups of countries that
were put together in order to take
advantage of the United States and we
don't want that to happen we're not
gonna let that happen
the China announcement up the anxiety
for some of the president's closest
political allies already suffering
heartburn over tariffs on steel and
aluminum well I'm concerned about it I'm
not a great fan of tariffs as everybody
knows but I will see what the president
thinks it's the right thing to do and
we'll go from there but I'm very
concerned about some of these tariff
ideas the National Association of
Manufacturers urged the president to
proceed with caution
in a statement this morning saying
tariffs are one proposed response but
they are likely to create new challenges
in the form of significant added costs
for manufacturers and American consumers
in addition to these challenges tariffs
also run the risk of provoking China to
take further destructive actions against
American manufacturing workers but in
another example of opposites attract
progressive Ohio senator sherrod Brown
applauded the move I appreciate the
president standing up and China
subsidizes its energy and its water and
its land and its capital I'm hopeful the
president puts as much interest in
workers as he does intellectual property
though I
support him on both President Trump also
wants to impose new investment
restrictions on China to stop them from
gobbling up US companies leading the
future of technological innovation the
tariffs regime hasn't yet been fully
formed but China is already laying down
a marker indicating it may retaliate but
China's foreign ministry also holding up
the hope for compromise so you see we
hope the two sides can have a talk with
level heads and work out a mutually
beneficial solution through constructive
dialogue and negotiation and on the
basis of mutual respect the president
disease today dismissed the notion that
the trade tariffs could ignite a trade
war with China saying that China needs
the u.s. more than the US needs China
and that the Chinese would be foolish to
risk that relationship but late this
afternoon Chinese officials saying they
are neither afraid of nor will recoil
from a trade war Chris John Roberts
reporting from the White House John
thanks for that